depuis la sphère du baiser fougueux la
langue contre langues
un bien sûr de la galoche infernal 1
comme on l'appelle la ssii la giraille
la galoche infernale entre isabelle et
gilles où en sommes-nous je rappelle que
si cette histoire s'est passé mercredi
mardi mardi mercredi mardi soir gilles a
dormi dehors
mercredi soir gilles a dormi dehors
jeudi soir il a regardé btp donc il n'a
pas dormi
j'aimerais savoir où on en est puisque
je suis vous avez rendez vous avec fatou
pour une séance de sport oui exactement
donc j'aimerais savoir où vous en êtes
déjà vous isabelle votre mari toujours
rien ils sont fous venons l'une à vue je
vais pas me la langue entend très bien
on rappelle bien entendu à ceux qui nous
rejoignent qu'elle n'a pas mis la langue
et lorsqu'elles étaient comestibles n
était la langue voilà merci voilà elle
peut dire cette murale son fils laurent
par les uns d'accord tous ses amis n'ont
parlé très bien gilles jaurès à boire et
les téléspectateurs veulent savoir où on
en est où
avec fatou tout de suite c'est le
hollandais ou avec fat ou alors il
faudra faire un ding de la série - au
nom mais au goût avec fatou a déjà ce
que je voudrais dire c'est remercier
tout le monde ici vous parce que tout le
monde est hyper gentil avec moi
valérie on parle beaucoup qui est lui
aussi jean michel m'a proposé de venir
habiter chez lui ah oui alors il n'y
avait pas à léona nom n'est pas parce
que je pense que là vous ne reverrez
vraiment vraiment là c'est à l'amour
mais je suis franchement n'allait pas
parce que là là c'est sûr et certain la
lafa tout s'est terminé du passager vue
matin à bâle chez lui la tête inquiets
du passage tandis qu'hier généraux à bas
ou non n'y allez pas c'est l'île de la
tentation
pas du tout là on va avoir pas tout dans
une semaine
qu'avez vous vu qu'à des bottes en vue
alors on s'est vus vendredi pour la
séance de sport alors s'il est à quelle
heure je veux tous les détails la selo
pj de nuit qui vous parle alors on avait
rendez vous à 10 heures donc déjà après
on discutait des organisations -environ
des bois 10 heures avec fatou d'avoir
donc on a fait la science
d'électrostimulation j'avais fait
d'aucune essonne ce d'électrostimulation
comment comment vous vous êtes dit
bonjour oui oui je suis entré dans
l'institut elle m'a dit bonjour monsieur
non alors elle avait ses lunettes c'est
peut-être vous a pas reconnu comme un
style pour ces professionnels des
centres et d'y arriver dans l'institut
d'afat boukella elle nous dit bonjour
meutrier ben oui parce que je suis
client donc cesser d'arrêter laissez
nous rire toi tu rentre chez lui on va
arrêter alors gentil bonjour monsieur
donc on a fait la meilleure une vanne
genre d'arkham moyens une vague de badme
raison non c'est pas l'heure de la vanne
donc c'est la très bonne séance d'abord
on a rien à [ __ ] rien demandé je suis
privé de la séance sur mon cou elle elle
l'a fait avec vous la séance oui c'est
ça qui me fait ben oui c'est en bout ce
qui me côte
elle nous dit quoi on n'a pas dit c'est
en le ventre contre aq contre 1 contre
accès y perd on est on est on est coach
avec la caf où il faudrait pas chez toi
même nom mais jeune homme et je demande
ça s'est super bien passé
après je suis resté et puis on s'est
revu beaucoup de la journée de dimanche
donc on a beaucoup parlé on a voilà on a
parlé de moi à parler on a parlé
beaucoup le dimanche au qu'est-ce que
vous avez repris ou non non non non
c'est alors le tournant elle ébranle a
parlé de travail de ne pas du baiser
volé non on n'a pas parlé du baiser on
n'a pas parlé de nous on a on a on était
comme des amis et honnêtement je vais
vous dire je ne sais pas où j'en suis
aujourd'hui
mais ces outils sincèrement fatou était
très agréable ce week-end très
disponible parce que j'ai des conseils
lui demander pour le travail mais elles
et les conseils elle je lui demande des
conseils et moi vous me demandez pas moi
c'est vrai ça oui je veux pas vous aimez
ou vous ennuie mais vous me suis pas du
tout c'est quoi les conseils on peut
défendre mais non mais j'ai juillet une
demande tu as des projets sur l'avenir
sur l'avenir il est ici pour toi que
l'état va bien mais lui sait et elle me
conseille on parle on parle de
l'institut on parle de travail que tu
connais institut doit soupeser ses de
l'esthétisme mais quand jeudi soir un
sujet qui fâche
oui et c'est le juge parce que fatou est
insondable quoi aujourd'hui il fatto
être un as ondes à l'abri j'appelle
ipsos je ne sais pas ce qu'elle pense
que tu as essayé dé renom toujours pas
du tout bêtement je vais vous dire
l'heure n'était pas venu ce week-end
n'ont vraiment non alors si vous avez
des questions chez vous c'est maintenant
sur twitter bien sûr hashtag fatou et
gilles bien entendu nous demandez et
vous ne posez des questions juste là
aujourd'hui je peux me permettre de te
donne un conseil pas fait attention de
ne pas passer dans ce qu'on appelle la
fredzone voilà la fredzone elle est
terrible c'est ça tu te fais friends
sonné s'est terminé 0
alors attention si j'étais toi et je te
conseille je sais que fatou nous
regardent et fatou et moi on est comme
ça je rappelle qu'on est du produit même
des camps tous les deux balances pas
tout et moi balance elle et du kwh à
22,73 ses moulins 12 septembre à 12
septembre j'avais dix jours de retard
mais je me pose
voilà je te le dis si j'étais toi sais
où tu coupes complètement les ponts au
renoma sinon je vous le dis encore une
bosse il faut couper les ponts
complètement et par quelles voies que
vraiment l aele
elle tient à toi arrive que devait
perdre au dessus des mecs château voilà
sinon si elle a le beurre et l'argent du
beurre parce que là elle est copine avec
toi donc elle te parle de ces trucs tout
ça mais après si chacun chez soi et les
moutons sont bien car il s'est passé non
mais c'est pas ça le fait que j'aie qui
alors vous êtes timide
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a donc fait un raisonnement d'hommes
il se dit je ne vais pas aborder le
sujet et ça va peut-être passer comme ça
c'est sa voix s'est passé c'est ça que
dans ta tête comme ça les aubrais un
coût et en effet je suis d'accord avec
siri ça me semble pas être la bonne
technologie ne le comprends et je ferais
la même chose à sa place
mais ce qu'il faudrait pas que depuis
qu'ils essaient de la reconquérir
aujourd'hui alors moi je pense qu'il
faut un cadeau à la temps un cadeau
elle attend cadre symbole est là tant qu
un symbole elle attend qu'elle a fait
bien peu il montre je pense une lettre
pour imbriquer doit justement que tu lui
fait trop de cadeaux aux habituels
agathe trop elle en a marre de toi il
faut que tu la lâche alors donnez vos
conseils de trois conseils la sur
twitter de trois questions sur les plus
justes il
il a un peu en temps en temps je veux
pas vendre et mais bien peu entendons
qui a fait ça c'est à lui d'aller voir
faute vous dites je dois lui dire barre
toi fais le mort effet pu alors vous
êtes si je peux me permettre la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
ouais bah toi et énervé tueur retourne
la situation oui
est ce que j'aurai voilà là moi je
rappelle à tout récemment tu me laisses
pas faire mon travail pas bravo c'est
chaud à tous voilà donc je te dire les
maisons que fatou c'est ça que tu fais
moi j'aurais retourner la situation et
la fin tout seul serait là elle serait
là à la place de mokhtar un comme ça en
attente mais en attente d'un signe de
toi a demandé pardon
là vous avez raison c'est faux pas que
gilles se victimise wallabies
éternellement
exactement ms a fait le boulot tout
excuser maintenant tu fais tu as dit et
puis la rue galos aller voilà là mais je
te le dis tu as fait le boulot 6-23 mois
écoute moi alors je vais te dire
franchement si fais moi plaisir écoute
moi je te le dis regardez si j'avais
parlé du mariage
ah ouais pas mal valentin est ce que tu
leur demanderai pas encore en mariage
mais bon j'ai passé j'ai pas fournir la
bague à chaque fois je suis pas
bijoutiers non mais je te le dis non
mais alors donc ben non mais non le
temps j'écoute vos conseils mais le
temps n'est pas venu
moi je suis d'accord avec le mot
reconquérir et moi ton recontre avec ça
fait déjà plus de dix ans est en
reconquête
si cela s'était bien non m'arrête c'est
une il ya le voit bien pour l'instant
moi je vais te dire ça et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs on en direct et moi je
dis tout quoi je t'explique c'est un
tournant dans ta relation ça c'est où
vous allez vous marier mort là ou bien
non ça va se terminer
moi si j'ai un conseil à donner je vais
tenir la tap à la bonne porte
oui oui oui t'as pas la vôtre mais qu on
va faire on va faire on va faire un truc
en trois tons a en premier temps ce
qu'on appelle le black out plus de
nouvelles et sommes pleins sms plein
appel c'est qu'elle a rendez vous demain
avec m on va faire quoi
on va voir le comptable demain 14h
annuler ah non non non mais c'est moi
qui vais demander la nullité faire des
conneries ce qu'après écouteurs
ce qu'on appelle le black out rien
terminé plus nouvelle mal sa passe au
numéro ça c'est des gamins et qui lui
répond sms pas il répond mais c'est
black out solennellement même pas tu
réponds même même pas c'est terminé ici
laissez moi faire ça c'est le premier
c'est moi faire 2e dans un deuxième
temps là elle va vouloir te voir là tu y
vas et là tu mets tout à plat tuéni
voilà des nouvelles règles fatou ouais
ouais tu connais à l'aller à tous a
récemment passé ça pour toi bien je
connais pas ton match que des fans et
envie de ça va être quoi étonner fatou
ce qu'elle donne c'est un mec qui tape
du poing sur la table il n'y a aucun
j'en ai ras le cul de toi tu commences à
oui mais je le dis aux téléspectateurs
si tu dis aux joueurs actuels première
il n'a pas les risques c'est quand même
la première étape au niveau des beckham
va revenir sur le permettent il faut
qu'il apprenne à l'envers ah oui à tout
[Applaudissements]
écoutez c'était ma troisième face à pato
je voulais ça va trop vite trop trop
trop forte
il vous plaît c'est que je te conseille
l'argile jolie et écoutez moi c'est
monté écoutez moi je vous le jure donc
la black out deuxième phase les
nouvelles règles pas tout j'ai mon
travail j'ai mon truc je vois là quand
je travaille je travaille moi je suis à
la maison je la maison maintenant c'est
le donc on va on va parce que je sais
que c'est elle qui décide de tout
maintenant on va décider à cinq contrats
là voilà on décide à 5 contre 50 pour
les décisions ensemble together main
dans la main on est d'accord et 3e
troisième truc là un cadeau un cadeau un
après un cadeau car enfin pas tous
maintenant que mon ami tout au clair je
te veux pour femmes
voici le cadeau et la rivière de
diamants méridien à l'acte ou un petit
une marque une marge au diamant et vous
mettez en corps et en voyage d'accord
mais un voyage ou un voyage est un petit
bijou
oui là tu prends tu fais le voyage là
dans l'avion tu sors le bijou pas tout
mais tu m'épouser
[Rires]
c'est ça c'est ça et tu verra après tu
mets ram tu veux remercier l'inquiète
nom écrit en tout cas un homme et non
pas du tout mais moi je me sois
conseillère les conseilleurs ne sont pas
les pays acp conseillère et m'inquiète
c'est qu'il a l'air beaucoup plus paumés
qu'avant l'émission hier face qui me
pose problème à avancer les soins à
faire
et n'oublie pas alors je vous le dis à
tous les téléspectateurs le black out
c'est à dire à son clean nouvelle f60
nouvelle ça a marché
et bien sachez le même si vous n'avez
pas la cote avec la meuf
même si vous n'avez aucun bail à cannes
même si elle vous kiffe pas une baffe à
qui vous ne donnait plus de nouvelles ou
un mec qui vous nous donner plus de
nouvelles il dira pourquoi ne donne plus
de nouvelles
et oui même s'il s'en fout et là je vous
allez le pic est atteint comme ça et aux
missiles et au bout de quatre en effet
il est continu à plus de 4 ha pour toi
des questions c'est toujours proposé
c'est que tous les jours à 19h07
vous pouvez m'envoyer vos problèmes où
je prendrai mettre des gens au téléphone
et je redonnerai mais conseille
gentiment trompeur leur écran voilà
d'accord mais vous êtes d'accord on va
appeler sa baballe
les gens appellent directement ou vers
et à partir de demain j'ai besoin que
leurs conseils
quant à m
[Applaudissements]